- I don't even know what to do at this point [laugh].
So I just, like, tried to catch it?
But then back away from it at the same time
cuz it wasn’t my job.
And then I just opened my eyes and,
like, "Ahhh!" We don't have the ball.
♪♪♪
- [Master Tesfatsion:] Brandon Bostick.
[Clap]
How you doin', bro?
- I'm good, man. How 'bout you?
- Good, man.
How's life been treatin' you outside of football?
- It's been good. You know, just training kids.
Tryna stay involved in the game, stuff like that.
- So when's the last time you played pool?
- [Brandon Bostick:] Man, it's been a while.
But I can beat you, though.
I heard you ain't no good, though.
- Man, wha—everybody wanna talk noi—?
Go ahead—break. We gonna see what you got.
[Pool balls colliding and knocking]
OK.
- So, Brandon, we're talkin' about the playoffs.
And obviously during your time with the Green Bay Packers,
you're goin' to the NFC Championship Game.
- [Brandon:] Yup.
- How different is that experience in Seattle
during a playoff game compared to
playing them on a regular-season game?
- [Brandon:] That’s one of the loudest stadiums,
so imagine tryna play that, imagine tryna
hear the quarterback callin' out these signals.
Imagine tryna hear the coaches.
Like, you, laser focus, your game plan is,
you're so locked in. You know,
I mean, you gotta be on your A-game to win there.
And that's what we was at that time.
- What do you remember from that first half?
- I just remember us just dominating.
Just, ah, that's good. Like, we ridin' high.
Like, things is just good. Like, we goin' to the Super Bowl.
We 16-nothing. Let’s just keep that foot on their throats
and just finish this game.
- [Master:] Mmhmm.
- And we're gettin’ ready for the Super Bowl.
- So we're gonna fast forward now. Two minutes left,
Russell Wilson scores a touchdown—19-14.
Packers are up.
- [Brandon:] Yup.
- They're comin' up for the onside kick.
What was your role on the onside kick?
- [Brandon] In football, like, L means left,
so I had—1, 2, 3, 4, like, the fourth guy in.
So L4 was my guy, I had to block that guy.
- You're standing there.
What do you recall from that play?
- That's the first time in my life I've ever
been on a live onside kick.
So, like, you know, he kicked the ball.
And I'm just, um, at that time, like,
OK, I got my guy.
But at the same time, my reaction kicks in.
"Oh, see the ball. Get ball." But, no, that ain't your job.
So I'm kinda in between blocking and jumping at the same time.
So I'm like, "I don't even know what to do at this point.”
So I just, like, tried to catch it?
But then back away from it at the same time cuz it wasn’t my job.
And then I just opened my eyes and, like,
"Ahhh!" We don't have the ball.
- Mmhmm.
- [Brandon:] I just remember them screaming they had the ball.
I'm, like, damn. I'm walkin' back to the sideline.
People are like, "What the—? What the—?
Like, what the fuck are you doin'?
Like, you're supposed to block." I'm like,
I don't, I don't even think I ever said somethin'.
I just, like, went and sat on the bench with my head down.
I'll never forget, like, I Googled myself.
I'm, like, I wanna see what, like, what people sayin'.
And I always see that picture of me just, like—
[Master laughing]
- sittin' on the bench with my head. I'm, like, damn,
that was a low point in my life.
Football is a momentum game.
So once I blew—pretty much blew the game,
the momentum was all on their side.
The stadium's at the loudest it could be at this point.
We were just stuck on my play.
We couldn't really get over it, so it just,
everything just fell down from then.
I felt like I was the reason we lost.
But at the same time, there was a lot of game left.
We should've won. So, I don't know.
It just—I still struggle with it daily.
I'm, like, damn, what, you know, what we coulda been.
But, you know, I try not to think like that.
I try to live in the present.
[Pool stick connecting with ball, balls colliding]
That's in there.
- [Master:] Game's over. Packers lose.
What's goin' on in the locker room?
- [Brandon:] I, I remember, uh, actually cryin' at this point.
I'm, like, damn. Like, I don't even know.
Like, what do I even do?
Like, I never really face adversity like this.
Small-town kid—you know, I reached my dreams, just growin’ up.
Everything was—I mean, a couple of bumps in the road,
but everything was so sweet, like, just gettin' there.
And I think that was the first time I actually,
like, damn, like, I was just overwhelmed.
I just remember goin' back on the plane, hoodie on, like,
I'm just, nobody gonna see me.
So I just sneak on the back of the plane. My phone's blowin' up.
My mom's callin' me. Like, I'm like, I'm not dealing with anybody.
So I'm not talkin' to anybody at this point. I just isolated myself.
- So your phone, all the text messages, all the phone calls,
you were just putting on do not disturb?
- Yeah, I think my phone mighta, like, crashed.
I was gettin' so many social media, like—
Instagram, Facebook, just text messages, like,
death threats from a football game. I'm gettin' the racists.
I'm gettin' all this crazy stuff.
Like, even it got to a point where my agent reached out to me,
like, "Do you want, like, a personal security guard?"
I'm like, "No," like.
- [Master:] Wow.
- "I'm, uh, I'm good."
The next morning, we had a team meeting, though.
So, all teams have, like, an exit interview, they call it.
Every player talks to the coach.
So I get there. And it's Mike McCarthy.
I'm like, "Hey, what's up?"
Still got my hoodie on from the night before, like.
- Did you change at all?
- I don't even think I went to sleep that night.
He's like, "Uh, you had a good year." Blah, blah, blah.
"You need to work on this, work on that."
So I'm like, "How do you feel?
Like, am I gonna be here next year?"
He's like, "Yeah, I like you." Like, "You have potential."
Like, "You're one of the top tight ends.
You know, we look forward to having you."
So I'm like, "OK, cool." I felt, I felt good.
That's the first time someone—good—said somethin' to me.
OK, cool. My coach feels good about me.
I'm good next year. I can just, you know, just go train.
And I'll make the team next year. I’m good.
So that was good for me at the time.
Offseason, we all go to, all my boys go to Miami.
We partied just nonstop, just—
- Were you partying to cope?
Or were you partying to—? What was—?
- [Brandon:] I was partying just to get away from it.
Like, I guess coping. So I was just, I don't know.
Uh, I think I was depressed, for sure depressed,
but I don't know. Like, growin' up in South Carolina
there's no, like—just suck it up.
You can't really show your feelings or show any weaknesses,
you know? So I just partied. That was my thing.
Go to Houston—party.
I got a call from a Green Bay number.
I'm like, "Who's calling me from Green Bay?"
I'm wasted, like, hungover.
He's like, "This is, um, Eliot Wolf, the personnel guy."
So I'm like, "What's up?"
He's like, "Um, you know, I think—we had a talk.
I think we're gonna release you."
I'm like, "OK."
Then my agent calls me.
Like, "Yeah, the Packers are gonna release you."
I'm like, "I just talked to Mike McCarthy.
He said I was good. Like, what's up?"
He's like, "Nah, they're gonna release you."
I'm like, "Are you serious?"
"Yeah."
So I got released. I'm goin' back on the plane.
- From Houston to—
- Houston to Green Bay—I just got cut.
I'm goin' to get all my stuff. And then I see Mike McCarthy.
I'm, like, damn. That's crazy. Like—
- He's on the plane?
- He's on the plane. Goin' back to Green Bay.
Waitin' on the Uber and it's crazy—he's standing right beside me.
I'm, like, damn, like, you have nothing to say? Like?
- He didn't talk to you at all one bit?
-  He didn't talk to me at all. Like, man to man?
Nothin' to say.
So then I go, like, clean out my stuff,
and that was the end of that.
- Have you ever felt that depre—
that kind of depression before?
- Like, the more I mature, I'm, like, damn, I really was depressed.
Like, that was a dark time in my life.
Like, no one, no one loved me.
Everyone hated me. Like, whatever I did was wrong.
Like, everyone—like, I remember just goin' to, to Minnesota.
They, uh, they signed me, so I'm, like,
I'm goin' there. So I just remember goin' there.
We're at practice. First route I ran, I dropped the ball.
I'm, like, goddamn, I still, like—
—the Seahawks game was the last play.
So the next play I'm on the field is with the Vikings.
I dropped the ball, and I'm, like, damn, this is terrible.
At that time, I'm still depressed. Like, I'm partying.
Went to Arizona—just partying, just goin' crazy,
not really focusing on football.
So, that's when I felt like, m-man, I need to get serious.
Like, my career's gonna be over soon.
Then I just, like, refocused. I went back to the basics—
just what got me there. Like my mentality from South Carolina.
Like, I gotta make a play, so.
I had to, like, refocus on that and just find myself again.
- What did you learn about yourself?
- Man, I learned so—I'm still learnin' to this day.
Just, like, how to face stuff and just, like,
how to respond. Like, now, like, nothin'—
I feel like I'm bulletproof. Like, nothin',
like, whatever happens to me, I know how to handle it.
[Pool stick connecting with ball, balls colliding]
- [Master:] Go.
Have you ever talked to or seen Aaron Rodgers since that play?
- Uh, yeah, actually I saw him in L.A., just, uh—
I don't remember. 2015? 2016? Just walkin' down Hollywood.
I'm like, "What's up, Aaron Rodgers?!"
Obviously I didn't say "Aaron Rodgers."
[Master laughing]
I'm like, "Whassup, bro?"
Just, like, uh, "What's up, man? How's it goin'?"
He's just, like, talkin' to me. He's like, "Hey," like, uh,
"I really appreciate, you know, what all you did for us.
Like, that play—it's a big play but I understand."
Like other stuff like that.
So I just said to him personally, man to man,
I'm like, "Man, I'm sorry.
You know, I feel like I let you down."
- What would it mean, like, if
the Packers make it to the Super Bowl?
- It would mean everything to me, bro.
Like, I don’t know, I might even go, so.
I just want the Packers to win the Super Bowl
so they can get off my back, so I won't get all these
Instagram and, uh, Twitter messages.
- Thanks for kickin' with us.
Subscribe to B/R
to check out more dope videos like this one.